[Music]
we're here at gary door elementary
kicking off the
chess cops program it's a partnership
between st
louis police departments st louis area
schools and the st
louis chess club it introduces officers
to the game of chess and allows them to
go out into the community
and have a chance to play against some
of the best and brightest kids in st
louis
it's really encouraging to see this
really large turnout
i think it's the largest turnout we've
had for chess cops event
thus far so it was really encouraging
well this is a great program i i can't
think of
of all the things we do in the chess
club and there are a lot of great things
this one i think is the most important
for the community and the city
and the region because it gets children
together with police officers
in a very positive setting and i think
it's going to educate
both of them and it's going to cement
relationships between
the police and the communities now they
get to see police officers in a light
they've never experienced
now when they see one they can think
chess they can think fun
i think it's just astonishing really you
get this contribution in the community i
think it's going to build bridges
it's going to bring people together it's
going to bring the police officers
together with the young people
and then the whole community is going to
rally around it so it's going to have
just a transformative effect
on the community i think the kids get to
interact
in a one-on-one basis with the police
officer in a friendly environment
and also they're getting the benefits of
the game of chess and i think it bodes
well for the future with getting more
kids into the stem
areas you know science and math things
like that so
i think the kids benefit in a variety of
ways police officer you'll expect to be
good
and you might manage to beat them like
like say because i'm only 12 not being
like people who's dirty and stuff
it feels bad because like you see them
controlling like your city and stuff
and you say oh i won't play them in the
game the chess one they see how good
they are
it's a police officer that you don't
know it all
instead of your friends at school it was
fun playing the police officers because
some of them was good some of it wasn't
and some of them
had very good moves that i never learned
for
and to give the kids an opportunity to
see the police
not as adversaries but really
as opponents and fun games so they're
building this relationship
over sports and you don't get to see
that anywhere else in the world
and for me to come this morning and
witness it it's been an amazing
experience
i hope i can bring it back to my country
i hope for the program to expand
and uh again to serve the entire
community and the entire region
just to increase the number of officers
the number of schools involved and
ultimately
this breakfast and this event is all
about exposing our children
to the leaders of the community and to
the game of chess so it's showing
how our students are able to be what
they see if they're able to see great
leadership if they were to see great
thinkers then they can be
great thinkers and they can become great
leaders chess has such amazing benefits
for young people
and to see the bridges being built here
you have to hope it's going to sow the
seeds
for more community engagement in cities
around the country
today was an amazing day we're happy
that we're able to kick this program
off and we really look forward to what
it will bring